I mentioned former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton she's she's been
everywhere mm-hmm she's on Nickelodeon
with her book drawer the Explorer
showing her book to backpack hi I got in
my car last night she was in the
backseat yeah I know she rose up like
animal hit and he got an ID book here
everywhere medicine cabinet book Hillary
Clinton's everywhere and she appeared on
Fox News to discuss her new book hard
choices now I watched it and maybe it
was just me
brett-brett bears interview seemed a
little hung up on one topic if he asked
me take a look and we are pleased to
welcome to our set former Secretary of
State former New York senator and former
First Lady Hillary Clinton author of the
current best-selling book hard choices
let's begin
I'm madam secretary obviously the big
news today is on Benghazi mm-hmm so I
guess the question is why is there Ghazi
Benghazi mm-hmm I wrote about this at
length in my book a whole chapter I have
some more specific Benghazi questions
you may have a imagine that you write in
your book that Benghazi was probably the
most Benghazi Benghazi on Benghazi and I
want to move to st. Ghazi in the
Benghazi chapter you acknowledge that
you had a Benghazi Benghazi your
testimony before the Senate on Benghazi
in January 2013 you stated our
commitment to read gossip goes back to
the Benghazi the bank backs I do Brett
[Applause]
[Music]